you  you  you  [Music]  the letter clearly clearly states that  this is in celebration of the 30th  anniversary of the Berlin Wall it is of  course a reminder that all walls  ultimately fail and we have to be  intelligent about how we either fight  the root cause or whatever it may be  [Music]  we're gonna travel across the country  and we're gonna give people the  opportunity to see the wall to touch the  wall to live history of the close and  personal so we'll be stopping through  our towns across the way and allowing  people to see it ultimately we're gonna  reach San Diego and and we're gonna try  to place it very close to the existing  border wall  [Music]  I think a lot of people recognize that  that this is not a message to a  particular wall it is a message about  walls in general whether they be  physical interpretations of walls or the  you know psychological ones mental ones  intellectual ones the ultimate message  that we're trying to convey is walls  don't work